America hates moms America hates moms
America hates moms
thank you one Dad no
um you can tell that America hates moms
by our language we have words like son
of a
and
ew
gross it
mom's plan
isn't that just a dad
you can tell by our laws
we are the only developed Nation without
paid leave
the best way to get the government to
pay for your time off as a new mom is to
become a cop and shoot someone
relax you guys okay my brother's a cop
for the purposes of that joke
I don't have a brother
cop jokes in the show and
I want you to enjoy them
I don't have a lot of mom jokes because
no one wants to hear them
no one gives a about mom jokes
they're like the moms of jokes
my mom tried to follow me on Instagram
recently and I blocked her immediately
it felt like that moment in Jurassic
Park where they learn how to unlock
doors
she couldn't be here tonight because my
comedies not for everyone
I love my mom we get along great
um when I first came out as a comedian
she treated the news like there had been
a death in the family
she said I'd rather you be gay
because at least that's something you
can't control